then there is taiwan walker
out for his 14th start so andrew
mccutchen gets the first game off
against taiwan walking a fantastic
season going so far for taiwan
2.42 era 6-3 record the mets
are 10-3 in his starts i believe
oh dubal herrera leads off of the
phillies
herrera drops down a bunt walker pounces
on it quickly and makes it look easy
he was breaking for the third base line
before the contact
and handled that as well as you can
handle a bunch here is reese hoskins the
power hitting first baseman and hoskins
goes down swinging
and walker's got his first strike out of
the day two up and two down good choice
uh by taiwan walker we've seen
him in these first
12-13 starts 3-2 he's been going with
the fastball but against hoskins he opts
for the slider and now harper betting
278 with 10 home runs and he's been
getting his hits lately he hits this one
in the air to left field and tour of the
line comes dom smith
and taiwan walker's got himself a one
two three opening inning 28 year old
aaron nola five and four on the year an
era of 4.22 numbers are high for aaron
on a lot of levels
pitches per inning really stands out how
different it is this year compared to
the last couple years yeah definitely
not as efficient and a lot of these guys
in this lineup have had aaron's number
in the past one on the way there's a
breaking ball inside and it hits mcneal
so he got him on the foot with a
curveball and jeff mcneal goes down to
first and just like that the mets have
the lead off man on and francisco lindor
coming up
that slashed the other way and lindor
has got himself an extra base hank
mcneal on his way to third jankowski has
trouble picking it up mcneil will pull
in at third base and lindor has got an
opposite field doubled and the mets are
out quickly against aaron nolan more
like lindor the last 27 games leading
off this one with a double down the line
hitting the ball where it's pitch and
let's watch mcdeal after getting hit by
the pitch how is he getting around the
bases not pushing it coming back from
the hamstring injury ninth double of the
year for lindor second and third and
nobody out for michael conforto
swig at abyss he swung over top of a
curve ball that was a beautiful pitch
and one out here in the first that'll
bring up pete alonso
curveball swung out and missed he's got
back-to-back strikeouts with that curve
ball two outs here in the first and see
himself through this in it
and again another one with a lot of
depth all right go and get yourself out
of this aaron dominic smith the hitter
owen two
and a call strike three on the inside
corner beautiful pitch for marinola he
just struck out the last three hitters
rael mutto is having another terrific
year 383 on base percentage 2-1 real
muto reaches and pops the ball up to the
right side first baseman alonso closer
to second than first makes the one-hand
catch and there's one out two-two pitch
swing and a miss strike three walker
with a fastball throws it by alec baum
second strikeout for taiwan walker two
out travis jankowski coming up and
jankowski lifts one out to left and dom
smith is there
and that retires the side six up and six
down for taiwan walker to start the day
no score in the second home half of the
second inning at citi field james mccann
leads off for the mets
a strike three called right down the
chute that's four consecutive strikeouts
for aaron is kevin pilar
swinging a miss a change up that just
kept on darting down
beautiful change up like i said before
10 miles an hour difference between his
fastball and change and now giormay
swag it a miss i'll tell you what that
curveball has been beautiful today six
strikeouts in a row
for aaron nola
ronald reyes leads off he's listed at
5-8 but he says he's only 5-6 and walker
blows him away with a high fastball
that's the third strikeout for taiwan
who has set down the first seven herrera
bounced out back to walker his first
time as he bats here with nola at first
and two outs in the third inning
and walker picks off the inside corner
for a strike three call
taiwan's got four strikeouts in three
scoreless innings taiwan walker is a
0-38 hitter this year 3-2 pitch and a
strike three called seven in a row
on strikeouts for aaron nola that
establishes a career high it matches a
franchise record so that'll bring up
jeff mcneil
he's feeling it swinging a miss eight
consecutive strikeouts for aaron nola
that out not only increases his career
high it establishes a phillies franchise
record for consecutive k's
0-2 pitch coming
swag and a miss it's nine in a row for
aaron nolan nine strikeouts in a row he
is one off the major league record as he
sets the mets down in order so he has
nine strikeouts through the first three
innings
he's the first pitcher with nine
strikeouts for the first three innings
since uh the 2019 season and the two
swag and a miss he did it he ties tom
seaver's major league record for
consecutive strikeouts in a game he has
struck out 10 in a row
this is incredible on so many levels for
the phillies right-hander record set in
flushing
record tied
a few hundred yards away in flushing
one-two coming
and it's poked the other way and that's
a fair ball going into the corner alonzo
on his way to second it's bubbled by
harper alonso already broke it down he's
going to stop at second
nola settles for tying seavers record
alonso breaks it up with an opposite
field double now the mets with a runner
in scoring position and one down
and the batter is dominick smith
holds
into the shift maton gets to it to his
feet throws to first excellent play two
outs
over to third is alonso so two gone now
runner at third base and mccann will be
the batter he struck out looking his
first time up
swinging a miss he got it with a change
up that's 11 strikeouts through four
innings for aaron nola travis jankowski
takes the strike and it's owen two maybe
i went overboard the other day as
jankowski lines it back to walker and he
finds that little pearl
well we saw degrom make one reaching out
to his left the other day this was a
little scarier right over his head
remember coming out of the shadows too
so i don't know how he could see that
off the bat but he did because he put
both of his hands up right where he
thought the ball was going to be
and he found leather knocked him right
to his fanny ball four maiton walks
brings the hottest philly's hitter to
the plate in aranola who has one of the
two hits today but it was the hardest
hit ball
outward right center field on the run is
conforno he's not gonna get it it's
gonna get to the warning track bayton's
around third heading for home the throw
to the plate is not in time
rbi double for aaron nola that's right
exclamation point and the phillies take
the lead it's one to nothing here in the
top of the fifth inning
he's doing it all tom that is just
remarkable
that's why you cannot walk the
eight-hole hitter with two outs
only bad things could happen there
[Applause]
a very good thing for the fight and
fills
the reaction for the bench his buddy
zach eflin loving it getting involved
most emotional ever see aaron noah show
aaron will leave after allowing only two
hits
and striking out 12 which matched his
career high
including 10 in a row and jose alvarado
is on
well the mets have loaded the bases they
don't have a hit in the inning yeah the
one-two
swing and a miss he threw it again
huge strikeout with the bases loaded
mccann goes down swinging the stretch by
alvarado and the 1-0 offer swing and a
ground ball hit the short torreyas has
it feeds second and the job is done in
the sixth alvarado who has not recorded
a save of five outs or more in his
career
bouncer back toward the mound gloved by
alvarado
and his high throw is lost in the sun by
rhys hoskins and guillaume will go to
second and you just can't make this
stuff up gourmet now at third
representing the tying run but two men
away and it'll be up to francisco endor
to keep it going
and francisco lines one base head and
that'll tie the game
guillerme comes home
lindor with his second hit of the day
and the let's get even 1-1 it doesn't
matter neris alvarado or whomever else
the phillies pen doesn't get it done
francisco lindor does and pete alonso at
first after the intentional walk so the
mets begin this inning essentially with
runners on first and second nobody out
dominic smith stands in against the
lefty ranger suarez and he swings away
throws it up the middle base hit here
comes lindora third and the mitch win it
and dominic smith takes one swing to win
the game the mets beat the phillies 2-1
in the bottom of the eighth dominic
smith sends lindor home and now smith
being mobbed behind the second base bag
as a walk-off base hit brings the match
back to a victory over the phillies